the fastest way to accomplish anything
is to model someone who has already had
the same success that you are at you can
go around trying to figure out
everything by yourself trying to come up
with every new idea yourself and you
will slowly slowly make progress towards
your ideas but until you recognize that
success leaves clues that whatever the
thing is that you're trying to
accomplish has already been solved by
thousands and thousands of thousands of
people that all you need to do is model
the success Until you realize that
you're gonna constantly stay struggling
making slow progress knowing that you're
capable of more so I first learned the
power of violent success with my first
business where I was struggling I was 19
20 not making any money 300 bucks a
month low confidence filled with
self-doubt not getting results turn down
high paying jobs to do this thing and
own 30 of a company that seem to be
going nowhere and I told my partner that
I quit and the thing that saved me when
I hit my lowest point was I am not the
first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software from
Toronto who's done that before nobody
but a software company getting to a
million dollars somebody's done that
before how about I just look at their
success and try to emulate it and so the
only person I could think of off the top
of my head was Bill Gates so I looked at
Bill Gates and how he got started and it
was through Partnerships and I applied
that lesson to my business and in a
short amount of time had my first deal
for thirteen and a half thousand dollars
I felt like a rich man you know I felt
like holy cow and to go from 300 bucks a
month and and saying I quit to now
having a deal in place for 13 and a half
K and more important the strategy that I
could use again and again again was was
life-changing for me
all because I model success and that was
again when I was 1920 so now what have I
done for the past 20 years is just model
success what is my YouTube channel about
what is this video about a lot of
success why have these people behind me
it's not for you it's for me I want to
model success they're constantly pulling
me up to a greater spot whatever problem
you have has been solved not exactly the
specific minutia but by modeling Bill
Gates it took me 80 of the way
you still have to figure out that final
20 but most people are trying to figure
out the whole hundred that's the problem
I was struggling when I was trying to
figure out the whole hundred all by
myself it's just coming coming up with
new ideas new ways new innovation but
nothing worked
[Music]
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20 and so look to your Heroes look
to potential mentors whether you know
them in person or not they've done it
before they can teach you success leaves
Clues you don't have to go through this
alone and you can ramp up your success
really quickly rule number two fix your
thinking how you think about the problem
is the problem most people are locked
into losing thinking finding all the
reasons why you won't win if you're the
ant think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so I
used to think that introverts couldn't
win I used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a YouTube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time I hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting YouTube I started on my
website it was called devincharmacle.com
I didn't have a better name at the time
and I profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what I do on
YouTube but on my website because I
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and I wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so I always hid behind the
faces I remember my first banner I had
Howard Hughes a big Howard Hughes uh
Oprah Winfrey and a couple of people and
people kept asking me well where is Evan
Carmichael you know the website's off
your name you're putting this together
what's your story and I thought well who
cares about my story I mean sure I built
and sold my first business but it's
nothing compared to Howard Hues and
Oprah Winfrey's people have done great
things and it kept coming up over and
over and over again translate that to my
YouTube channel Evan Carmichael was
still the number one requested top ten
and when I first started doing top tens
we did Kanye West shout out to Kanye
there on the wall and then a bunch of
other people people kept asking for mine
like well what do you want mine you mean
again what have I done compared to Kanye
West and I always hid behind the fact
that I was an introvert and so I don't
want to share my story nobody is
interested I'm shy I'm I'm the
Wallflower I don't go off and try to
make myself the center of attention I
don't like you know hanging out with
people and so I had the story that
introverts Can't Win It wasn't until I
reframed it and thought you know what
introverts can win
in Communications because we're better
listeners I'm a great listener as much
as you might think I love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that I do what I love doing
more than that is listening and I think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk look at me
it's you're trying to help and I've met
some amazing introverts who are on a
huge Mission and why not have a big
impact and have to fight with themselves
to get out of the comfort zone and have
a spotlight on them instead of just
being behind the scenes but they're all
great listeners they become great
communicators because they're great
listeners and so the problem wasn't that
I'm an introvert the problem is how I
thought about the problem of being an
introvert rule number three take control
of your positions every time you say I
can't you're teaching yourself that you
suck because you've quit because you've
given up it's not your fault that you
can't do it it's your work or your
school or your family or all the other
commitments that you have but not your
fault nope
nope
nope
change your I can't to either I'm going
to or I choose not to that's how you
take back control of your decisions and
your life so I recently listened to this
Chinese song and I got obsessed with it
I got obsessed with it I was playing it
all day long and I just I loved I don't
know what they're saying I don't know
which I don't know what the words mean I
just love I loved it I loved it I go to
bed
and lyrics start coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up I'm in bed I'm
lying in bed trying to sleep you know
it's 11 o'clock trying to sleep constant
idea rap lyric come okay I write it down
again Rattlers come write it down more
and more and more write it down until
three in the morning I haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like I need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a rap
it's easy to get locked in into I can't
mode I can't do this I can't start that
I can't do a rap I didn't go to school
for that not that you go to school for
rap you know I didn't rap growing up I
don't have musical Talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect from me I can't rap
ah
that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then I spent the day rapping and
that night finished the video sent it
off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my
rap video now maybe you love it maybe
you hate it it's gotten some decent
responses it was tons of fun to put
together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are
all great micro moments to teach
yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but I tried it
I did it I released it expect the second
beginning that's okay it's normal it's
part of the process but in those moments
of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists
is where your Genius will come
I look at my top 10 series and partly
why I have Kanye on my wall because the
first video that I made was on Kanye
first top 10 was on Kanye was five years
into my YouTube career
I did a response to my friend Mark
Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially
I can't do this like I can't make a
video now on this I have all these other
commitments I have a full day ahead of
other stuff that I'm supposed to do and
said no I did action I'm just gonna do
it forget it I'm gonna make it and I
didn't expect it to do well luckily it
actually did and then that became this
whole thing of making I don't know how
many top tens hundreds maybe a thousand
I don't know how many top ten how many
times have I done I have no idea
but it started off as this idea
trust your ideas
stop saying I can't to yourself
this is where you need to take control
of your head and your heart you have to
make decisions with your heart and then
use your head to figure out how to do it
you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new I'm making it I'm going to make a
rap I'm gonna make a top 10 video I'm
gonna do anything outside my normal
thing right same for you anytime you're
doing something new it doesn't make
sense
because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense you're creating
something new and so your head your
logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job
is to to protect you and says don't do
that you can't do that
because one has never been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart
creates art your heart makes up a world
that hasn't existed before and so at the
very beginning of many projects you're
having your heart are against each other
your heart's saying I want to make this
your heads you can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum because you're you're heading
your heart are fighting you've got your
foot on the gas and the break at the
same time never moving knowing that
you're capable of more and so you make
the big decisions in your life with your
heart and then you rally your head to
say okay we're doing this I'm making the
rap video I'm making the top ten you're
gonna do your crazy idea and then your
head says ooh okay they're serious let's
figure out how not to die doing this
right let's figure out how to actually
make it work so you make the big
decisions in life with the heart and
then you use your head to figure out how
to go out and accomplish it rule number
four learn to reframe
change how you feel
the problem is most of the time we don't
catch our feelings if you're feeling
negative angry frustrated depressed it
doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're trying to accomplish you're not
going to give it your all and you're not
going to get results because of your
negative emotional state if you don't
start changing how you feel you're never
going to make progress on the goals that
you set for yourself so one of the
things I love doing whenever faced in a
negative situation is say it's the best
it's the best I'm wearing this hat says
Fanta because friend of the channel Mark
Drigger pointed out to me when I was
saying it's the best that I'm a reframer
I'm reframing I've never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting instead of it it pushes
you forward instead of it being a
negative thing that is all encompassing
and depressing and brings you down and
he said well you're always positive
because you're just a reframer and it he
has his anagram and I'm a number six or
something I don't know he he can give
you more details you want to know what
number you are and what it means go
follow mark.rigue on Instagram and ask
him but
I think that's some
that's something everybody can learn how
to reframe you take whatever negative
situation that's in front of you and say
this is the best right now this is the
best where this came from was I was on
an airplane from Vancouver to Los
Angeles and that's a five hour flight
give or take and I have to sit next to
this really smelly dude and there was no
other option I had to stay on the plane
I had to make my flight I had to speak
at this event the only other option was
get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly and sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know I hadn't
showered in in however long and just
he's stuck and in my head I'm trying to
find Solutions there's no Solutions and
so I'm upset I'm complaining you know
the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's
what happens in my head I say this is
the best this negative thing that's in
front of me right now this is the best
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of right and so he's sitting
right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in breathe that in
breathe in that smell breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not
that this one dude is not gonna ruin my
day and I feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that any time I'm
facing a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find somebody to blame
and say it's your fault now this is the
best this is my change to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself what is so
overwhelming so impossible so crazy that
is bringing you down you look at your
calendar you look at your list of emails
and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
if you believe that the thing that you
struggled with the most in life becomes
your calling for the rest of your life
the time that you struggled and suffered
the most as a human your your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened
that that massively negative thing the
most painful moment in your life
actually is the best
because it's going to allow you to serve
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
people through your purpose so that
negative thing's in front of you tell
yourself it's the best rule number five
change your calendar most people have
not taken control of their schedules you
wake up like an accident start
responding to other people's emergencies
and help other people build their dreams
instead of you building yours it's time
for a change you deserve better and this
video is going to show you how I think
one of the biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs don't take enough action
is because when you get motivated you
don't do enough you feel the motivation
you feel the boldness feel the
confidence but you're not taking enough
action you're not doing enough I
remember going to my first Tony Robbins
event this is before uh I knew Tony
one-on-one before I did the interview
with him on my channel I just went to
see what would the event be like I've
I've seen so many different videos of so
many different people and I felt like
you know what for most people going to
their event it'd probably be the same as
just watching on YouTube YouTube but for
Tony I felt you know what I think his
event might be different there's
something that tells me by going to his
event it'll be different than what I
just see on YouTube through the content
and so I went I went with my wife I went
with three people on my team I paid for
everyone to go out and went to our first
Tony Robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to Tony Robbins event it's on
fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're you're
breaking through limits it's it's
amazing by the end of the last day you
see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out where everybody's all pumped
up and energized like I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that
I remember one of the people that I
brought with me he's like yeah yeah I'm
gonna do all this stuff and he's like
yelling and so fired up and excited he's
like what are you doing Evan like I'm
looking at my calendar
because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because you're not making a
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to
at least for me I look immediately to my
calendar
so if my goal is now I want to be a big
YouTuber great when am I going to make
videos it's got to be in the calendar
it's not in the calendar it's never
going to happen and so anytime you want
to make a meaningful change you have the
default to thinking what am I going to
put into my calendar because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you maybe
Events maybe books podcasts awesome
you're getting it from somewhere you
feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes you know you get motivated for a
day or two it feels amazing and then you
fall back down to normal if you want
that dream life you want that next step
for yourself it's gonna come from
changing your habits changing what's in
your calendar to make sure that what you
say you want out of life you're actually
working towards making that happen rule
number six build trust if you want to
become a millionaire or influence a
million people you need to learn to
build trust this is where you can really
win as an entrepreneur because people
have a really hard time trusting big
companies to do the right thing so this
is where you win
you win by not trying to be exactly like
the big companies you win by showing
that you actually care and will do the
right thing by the customer so bringing
it to a YouTube world as an example I
think everybody should be responding to
all comments one of the things that I
believe in is every comment we try to
get a response to every comment gets a
response every comment gets a response
and at the beginning when you're doing a
YouTube channel it's easy my first video
on YouTube it took me a year to get
three comments I made a video within one
year there were only three comments on
that video the first comment was my mom
thank you Mom the second comment was my
older sister thank you Alexandra and the
third comment was from some random dude
a new somebody discovered my channel
right one year three comments those are
pretty easy to respond to right it's
super easy in the early days when you're
not getting comrades if you're getting a
comment a day a comment a week couple
comments a day it's easy to respond to
what happens when people's scale is they
stop responding to comments because they
don't know how to scale the business
because at the beginning they're doing
everything themselves and it doesn't
take up a lot of time but as you start
getting more comments it starts to take
up more time I get hundreds of comments
every day on my on my YouTube channel I
can't respond to every single comment
personally myself
if I could I could if I did it then I
wouldn't do anything else I'm gonna be
making this video because I was spending
all my time responding to people's
comments right that's the process but
just like any other business when you
start a business you're doing everything
yourself if you start selling flowers on
the street you're doing everything right
you got to find the flowers you got to
sell the flowers you got to distribute
the flowers you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower
store then you bring on a team right and
you have people who are selling flowers
for you and open this door for you
including the store for you you're still
doing work right you're doing more
important work you can't do all of the
tasks in the business at all times if
you're always doing everything you're
never going to scale
and so I believe that bigger YouTube
channels should hire a team to respond
to comments I have an awesome guy my
team named velco so you'll see
responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that I need to
see so if there's feedback or
suggestions or improvements I want to
see them if this criticism I want to see
it if it's just saying thank you Evan
for the video amazing I feel the love I
don't need to see all of those comments
that come in right I'll I'll sort
through some of them respond to some of
them but that's not gonna be the best
use of my time every day because then
I'm not making videos and so make that
equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard
easier to show care because you don't
have that many customers because maybe
you only have one customer and so you
can show them the love but as you scale
and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most
important element yourself because
that's the thing that drives it or you
have people on your team that really
show that love and support because you
want to make sure the customer feels
respected and appreciated it's really
easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and
scale your clients and so you need to
build and skill your culture alongside
rule number seven work hard hard work is
your ticket in no matter where you come
from what you look like what your skills
are hard work is always the ticket in
the odds might be against you awesome
now what quit on your dreams or keep
working hard how you answer that
question will change your life so I have
an agent in New York and when I first
started the agency I almost didn't get
in uh I didn't get in because I'm a
weird case for them my agent now he
looked at me back then and this must
have been six or seven years ago by now
and he said Evan I love your message the
problem is you're not a very good
communicator and that hurt at the
beginning because I had already done
some speaking gigs I'd already been
making videos for three or four years
you know I've had hundreds if not a
thousand videos already under my belt
and here he is saying that I suck at
communicating and he said the people
that he typically works with are people
who are already in media who have tons
of experience who are great in front of
the camera they need help with finding
their message he said for you I love
your message you've got a great message
you just suck at being a little
communicated like
and so like hey great well where do we
go from here and he said I'm gonna take
a flyer on you
I don't normally do this I'm going to
take a flyer on you and see where you go
and I I didn't want to waste my
opportunity I didn't even know that you
could get an agent as a as a business
person as an entrepreneur as a speaker I
mean I guess I heard a speaking houses
but an agent I thought more
entertainment or Sports not for business
so I didn't want to lose this
opportunity you know I didn't want to
regret not giving it my best and so I
said okay great tell me what I need to
do I'm the worst right now awesome I I
don't have the skills that everybody
else here has how can I get better what
do I need to do tell me and he said okay
so your first challenge is I need you to
make a bio video and I need you to tell
your story a foundation Story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and record
it and I'm going to look at it and I'm
going to give you my feedback on it okay
great so I recorded it the next day and
it was in the morning I recorded it sent
it to him he gave me feedback and then
at lunch I recorded it again he gave me
feedback I recorded again in the evening
and I did it 30 to 40 times that's a lot
over over the course of however many
days you know 10 to 12 days I guess uh I
recorded the video over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again every time you give me feedback I
do it again feedback do it again
and I got better and I got better and
over the course of a couple months
when I was making three videos a day
practicing sucking but just practicing
and trying to get better and listening
feedback and trying to improve I quickly
became the best case at the agency I
quickly became the number one person
from from views from subscribers from
Best Practices I copy what Evan's doing
now I'm being brought on to help them
with their clients and train some of
them on how they can get better on
YouTube and build their brand from being
the worst from the guy who almost didn't
get in
because the people who are joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're
having a hard time finding the time to
make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and I'm
making three a day even if I suck I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna outpace just
because I'm willing to work just because
I'm putting in the effort you might not
have the skills you might not have the
talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need
to have
how does an introvert
build a huge audience and and spread a
huge message and be famous on YouTube I
don't know I mean I'm working on it join
me on my journey we'll figure it out
together
that was my agent's concern when I first
got started and I'm I'm breaking the
mold and doing things in the way that I
haven't been done and you can do the
same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't
guarantee your success there's a lot of
people who work really hard and never
win a lot of people who work 12-hour
days and are doing minimum wage jobs
they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in The Agency were
working smart but we're making one video
a week
I was working less smart
but making three videos a day so I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna get smarter
I'm gonna make it faster I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you what I can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems that people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing but better
than being impatient with the results is
being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or My
Views it's not happening my first video
took me a year to get three comments and
the first come was my mom the second one
was my sister and the third was some
random dude right a year to get three
comments and two of the people were my
family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you applying
the right strategies get more frustrated
with yourself and your effort more than
that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that
equivalent of making three videos a day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win it might be
slower than you'd like but it's always
slower than you'd like but you will
eventually win because hard work is
always your ticket in rule number eight
develop new skills you will never lose
in life if you have valuable skills you
won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value the economy can collapse the
algorithms can change but as long as you
have a skill that solves problems for
people you will be safe so I'm seeing
this a lot in the YouTube world now I
have a new course out helping people get
to a million subscribers on YouTube we
can link up the description there if you
want in and people are saying well
should I still do YouTube is it too late
like YouTube won't be here in five years
or ten years or maybe it's gonna be the
next thing that should hop on it's not
about the platform like right now it's
winning the platform that is currently
winning you need to crush it right like
YouTube should be your home if you're
trying to make an impact you're trying
to be a thought leader you have a
message to spread YouTube has to be your
number one place it just has to be right
now otherwise you're not making a smart
decision but whether YouTube is still
around in 20 years five years doesn't
matter because the skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing I don't anticipate YouTube still
being around in 20 years but my ability
to make videos talking to a lens
that's not gonna go away that can serve
me for life right whether that's VR Evan
or hologram Evan you know coming into
your living room that's that's gonna be
me that's gonna be amazing I'm pumped I
look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about the economy going down
or the algorithm changing you've already
lost that's a losing mindset
when I was first starting my YouTube
channel
uh I always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win right you should see if
you're a small Creator on any platform
YouTube Instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts that's your greatest
Advantage you should be cheering you
should want more algorithm changes if
you look at a traditional established
boring Market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win right
financial markets can be hard to win
it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have who have Decades of
experience no more than you and it's
hard to close that gap of experience
with social media with YouTube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win that's how you get
ahead of them that's how you become the
top dog is because you're gonna go learn
the new algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform it happened for
Facebook every time they change your
algorithm or updated the the feed and
what was shown there people always freak
out and complain and they sign they want
petitions and like let's go back to what
it used to be don't sign those petitions
don't jump on that penguin that is loser
thinking never ever ever ever ever ever
ever do that it's loser thinking and
that's how most people think
that's a mindset shift that I want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to LeapFrog
everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering I
still get pumped for an algorithm change
me I mean now I'm at now I'm closer to
the top right I mean I don't know what
the top is I got too many subscribers
and 300 million views and all these
channels I still love it anytime an
algorithm change comes out I'm still
pumped train yourself Like A change is
coming I'm pumped get excited because
there's still people who are ahead of me
or even the people below me that I'm
competing with for for attention and for
space if they're sitting there
complaining about how it's changed and
they're dropping in their views awesome
I'll pick up those views because I'm
going to learn what the new algorithm is
all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforted
in the join a club and wish things could
be how they used to be but we're not
going back to that
So the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business some
of the greatest businesses in the world
were built in recession in depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second I
look at Jake Paul Logan Paul they
started on Vine right Vine was was their
claim to fame they had tons of success
in making these super short videos Vine
gets shut down right boom gone this is
don't put all your eggs in one basket I
think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on Vine and and then
Vine got shut down oh no what did they
do they moved to YouTube and started
crushing it millions of subscribers look
at their growth on YouTube over the past
I don't know two years three years blew
up why
didn't just come out of nowhere they had
the skill set they had the skill set
that they learned from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
YouTube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that whatever comes next
people are freaking out about the FTC
coming in and Kappa on YouTube okay so
if kids aren't able to get content on
YouTube where they're gonna go go be
there
instead of trying to fight
what is already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
going to be
embrace the change
that's where you that's where you can
win where everybody else is fighting and
angry and screaming and yelling and
complaining and wishing that it used to
be or quitting the platform and getting
upset go be where they're gonna be it's
it's easy it's a simple win most people
don't have that mindset it's why most
people lose why most businesses can
evolve most businesses shut down it's
people very rarely transition from one
platform to another from one business to
another even though they have the skill
sets and capabilities to do so because
they don't have the mindset to do so
people who crushed Myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms look at look at
Hollywood the rock is doing it Will
Smith is doing it moving from Hollywood
films to YouTube where's Brad Pitt
where's George Clooney like they're in a
dine industry they should be embracing
YouTube they don't want to they have the
skills they have the skills it's
transferable you don't think George
Clooney could come in and Crush YouTube
if you wanted to
of course you could calling you out
George Clooney let's go make it happen
all right it's just about picking up the
skill set that will keep you safe in any
environment but it's also having a
mindset to follow through and try the
new things instead of complaining about
the changes that are currently happening
rule number nine stop complaining the
easiest way to win is to do work that
you love making a new video is easy for
me I've done 6 000 plus videos I still
love them and still enjoy it but there
is a chandelier sitting in the trunk of
my car right now that I have no interest
in installing I have I have no idea how
to install a light I have no interest in
learning how to install the light and so
I've asked my friend Mark Draeger from
Fanta to come and help install the light
for me if you're doing a business that
you don't know and that you don't love
and you think it's just going to be easy
money newsflash it's never just easy
money you're going to lose you have to
go through what I call the blinders test
now blinders are things that people put
on horses so there's those black patches
that they put here on the side of the
horse so the horse doesn't get
distracted so the horse isn't like going
all over like this all they can see is
what's in front of them and it forces
them to just focus and go in front of
them now side note apparently they
actually have this for humans too and
some tech companies are using them where
they have blinders for humans that seems
a little crazier than me but listen if
blinders help you focus then by all
means go for it but you need to pass the
blinders test so what is a blinders test
for me it's those moments in time
where you have absolute Clarity for what
you need to do where you know where you
want to go where you have Direction and
purpose and this is the window that you
need to jump through for me right now
it's YouTube
yes I've been on the platform for over
10 years but this is a special moment in
time for YouTube right now for Evan
Carmichael plus YouTube right now I'm
hitting it on strides we've got I don't
know how many channels right now a lot
too many maybe but I want to have a
hundred channels this is a moment in
time YouTube's not going to be around
forever and it's going to morph and it's
going to become something else and I'm
gonna have different interests at some
point this is the moment of time that
you need to then push hard I see
opportunities as Windows there's this
window that's in front of you right now
and the windows open but it's not going
to be open Forever at some point that
window of opportunity is going to shut
and that's when people look back and say
I had as I could have done it and and
that other person they made so much
money off of my idea it wasn't your idea
they did it the only difference between
you and the people who are winning is
they started they did it they take
action every single day there's no
reason why that person can't be you you
have to jump through the window with
full force and put your blinders on and
stop thinking about everything else
that's around you that's if you have
absolute Clarity and direction
now there will be other moments in your
life and I think I think life moves like
this I think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute Clarity and
purpose and Direction and there'll be
other moments where you're not so sure
what to do
and then you have to open up the funnel
again
sticking to the blinders when you don't
know what you're doing is not a great
strategy this this happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs where they have focused
for their business but then they lose
interest in their business and then they
bought themselves a job and they're too
afraid to get out of that business
because of what it means because of the
opportunity cost because of everything
that they've they've sunk into the
business because people might say well
what a failure if they close now and
they should have been out of their
business three years ago but they're
still going don't let that be you you're
never gonna win doing work that you hate
if you don't like your business anymore
you need to adjust it or you need to
move on dump it move on to something
else if I stopped liking videos
I will just decide no more videos
happening sorry guys maybe sell it to
somebody else or just stop because I'm
not going to win doing work that I hate
either and so if you feel your foot kind
of pulling out of the water while you
still have some interest move on to the
next thing and so when you know what you
want to do you're focused hyper focused
that's all you're doing when you don't
know what you want to do you open up the
scope and that's okay and I think
everybody will go through these phases
in life you will have absolute Clarity
and so you need to go off and do instead
of finding all the reasons why you can't
do and when you don't know what you want
to do don't stress out and worry that
you don't know what you want to do try a
bunch of stuff say yes to everything pay
attention to the feeling the most
important thing when you're trying
something new is do you love the process
of it
not is this going to be your next big
opportunity did you love the process
even though you suck doing it I sucked
making my first video I love the process
I sucked when I first learned salsa
dancing I love the process you're
supposed to suck at the start that's
okay
you don't need to get instant results if
you love the process you will win if you
got instant results but you don't love
it you're never gonna win it's just
never gonna happen you're not gonna win
and so depending where you are on the
spectrum of absolute Clarity to having
no idea
dictates what your action should be when
you know what you need to do stop making
excuses stop having justifications and
just go off and do the damn thing and if
you don't know what you want to do then
explore stop feeling sorry for yourself
stop complaining it's okay explore you
will find the thing that then you can
focus on until the next time you expand
it rule number 10 love the process a
good question ask yourself is do you
actually love this do you want it badly
enough I love making videos I sucked at
the beginning I'm still working to get
better I've gotten better over the you
know decade I've been on YouTube I still
look forward to it I still love it I
still work every week creating content
for you guys we're putting out six
videos a day across the different
channels now it's it's wild it's crazy
and I still love it we're putting in the
work I'm putting in the work my team's
putting in the work because we still
actually love the process of doing it so
so many entrepreneurs quit and give up
because you'll say you'll do whatever it
takes but you're not going to if you
don't actually love the process you
don't actually love the work you will
not do whatever it takes you will only
force yourself to do something that you
hate for so long until you give up and
quit so a big reason why entrepreneurs
don't put in enough work is because you
just don't love it enough no I've got a
very special bonus tip on go Brick by
break that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day what is your single
biggest takeaway from this video what
are you going to do to take action if
you made it this far in the video and
you promise to take action after
watching we don't just watch a video we
do something I want to celebrate you
give me a hashtag believe in the comment
below if you want to go Brick by Brick
to make it stick you have to pay
attention to two critical pieces the
first is mindset the second is action
you need both or you're going to give up
on your goals you know you're capable of
something bigger but you'll give up
because you don't have these two simple
things settled out I'm gonna show you
how to fix them in this video step
number one is mindset what you think
you're capable of is what you're
actually capable of if you think you can
go off and do it you're much more likely
to do it but if in your head no matter
how many skills and resources and people
are telling you you're great if in your
head you don't believe you can do it
guess what's going to happen you're not
going to do it and so you can apply
Brick by Brick in a methodology that I
call Big Y little y your Big Y is the
big reason why you're doing this thing
why are you doing this thing your
purpose comes in your pain you got a big
goal big ambition you want to change the
world you have a huge impact right you
want to solve giant problems and change
people's lives right that's your big why
you want to put a dent in the universe
right you wanna you wanna make an impact
that's beyond your lifetime it's a huge
why I'm waking up trying to solve the
world's biggest problem I don't think
people believe in themselves enough I'm
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem I think that's the world's
biggest problem I'm never going to solve
it even if I touch a billion people I'm
never gonna solve it that's the best I
think you should wake up and have a Big
Y so big that you're never going to
accomplish it you're going to climb
forever you're going to be on your
journey forever forever forever it's the
best
and oftentimes that big mission that big
Vision you have is so motivating for you
that it gets you out of bed gets you
motivated like let's go here's what I'm
trying to do and it gets you pumped up
but
sometimes the big picture is too big
sometimes your big why right it's Big Y
little y sometimes the Big Y is so big
that you feel you can't do it
that you're not capable that you don't
have the skill sets that you'll never be
capable and so you throw in the towel
because it seems too big
and I get that too you know I'll look at
me and my goals of solving the world's
biggest problem and say who am I to
solved the world's biggest problem
right how how am I capable of going off
and doing that
and especially in my I'm trying to think
the last time I thought about that
especially in my earlier years as an
entrepreneur I really struggled with
that I I go do a speaking gig and and be
so fired up and so motivated like man I
know I'm crushing it I'm helping people
so much it's amazing this is this is
oxygen this is what I breathe is amazing
thank you so much
and then I wake up the next day and be
back to normal like oh can I do this I
don't know if I can do this because
there's lack of momentum and so that's
where the little y's come in and the
little Y is the reminder that what you
do is important I think it's I think
it's so important that you feel that the
work that you do is important
if you woke up and felt every day the
work you do matters means something it's
having an impact man the commitment
level you're gonna have is so much
greater than if you feel like nobody
cares what's the big deal meh okay so
how do you remind yourself that the work
you do on a daily basis is important to
at least one person that's the little
why the big wise the big Vision big
dream big big mission like where are you
going awesome the little lie is you may
not be able to help a billion people but
you can help one
just reminding yourself that you help
one person how I get that now is in my
YouTube comments even now as part of my
morning routine I go to my YouTube
comments and I just see what people are
are saying
and these are people that you you know
amazing people who many many of whom
I've never met and maybe never will meet
hopefully hope they'll meet you come on
my tour meet me on tour probably I won't
meet most of you
and to see the warmth and the love and
the and the comments that you guys are
leaving makes me feel like this is why I
do it this is why it matters this work
matters if I stop doing this it would it
would mean something to people and they
you'd have to go somewhere else now not
so full of myself that you couldn't find
another solution but the work that I do
matters and your comments feed me every
day
I'm spoiled now that we get hundreds of
comments and tons of DMS and lots of
messages that come in Daily but when I
was first getting started
I didn't get that money when I talked
about my early days as a speaker I would
speak and have a great time and then the
next day wake up and feel like what's
the point I would say the thing that
made the difference was I would save the
messages that people sent me or emailed
me or said at the end of one of my
workshops and I would put them together
in a PowerPoint file and I would watch
that PowerPoint file every morning that
became part of my morning routine this
is when I really first started doing
morning routines this is this was such
an important piece for me was showing
the messages from these people as a
reminder every day that what I do makes
a difference and maybe I will never hit
my billion but these 18 people that I
helped I helped them that was me I did
that right if you felt like you helped
some people every single day
even if just remembering old people that
you helped every day as a reminder it'll
give you the ammunition the momentum the
fuel that you need to keep going every
day so Brick by Brick sometimes it's Big
Y right it's the mindset sometimes it's
the big why sometimes it's just man I'm
gonna go crush the world I'm so excited
I'm gonna go solve this giant problem
and and change Humanity right sometimes
you feel like that and it's amazing and
you go you go you use that boldness and
energy to create something amazing
and sometimes you're going to feel like
I can't do that big thing and so you
just look at the comments you look at
the the one person that you helped or
the five people that you helped or think
back the people that you have helped in
your life to remind yourself that you
are valuable that you make a difference
the work you create is Meaningful and to
get the momentum and energy you need
because for the most part the biggest
thing you're missing is just momentum
and momentum comes from mindset if you
believe you can create great things you
can so Brick by Brick starts with
mindset Big Y and little y so I said
there were two things right there's
mindset and then there's action so step
number two is action so you you think
you can do something then you have to go
off and do it thinking it is not enough
you got to do something you got to act
on it and Brick by Brick here is we
often will plan this giant thing right
you have this bold Vision this big idea
amazing and you default into planning
mode and you think I gotta do this and
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and it's
exciting and it's fulfilling it's
amazing to think in planning mode of
what you can potentially build but then
you step back and look at that Behemoth
that you just built in your head or on
paper and you think wow that's really
big
to do that I need I need venture capital
I need Partners I need I need I need a
team I need and all this all the stuff
that you need that you don't have
and then that becomes scary and then you
don't act and so I believe in what I
call the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you
come up with an idea
we're taking immediate action on the
first two percent so what we typically
do is we'll plan to get to 100 you'll
plan to 100 you'll plan your your entire
Vision out until it's complete right
then that becomes too scary instead of
planning as your first step plan is
important but it's not the first step
your first step is action your first
step is doing your first step is the
first two percent what is the first two
percent version so if your plan is to
build the next YouTube channel it's
gonna dominate the world I love it
it's easy to think while in the camera
personally the team I need an editor and
I need a scriptwriter I need I need I
need I need anything great awesome two
percent difference take your phone make
a video today teach yourself to go from
idea to action idea to action the
smallest possible version that little
video you make from your phone what
difference is going to make not a lot in
terms of output but a ton in terms of
momentum a ton in terms of momentum most
people just don't start if you want to
lose weight you want to get in shape the
best thing you can do is do 10 push-ups
right now I had a person in one of my
Lives who said that their goal was to to
get in shape okay great
go do 10 push-ups right now don't don't
come back on into the live until you've
done 10 push-ups are those 10 push-ups
going to actually make that person lose
20 pounds of course not
but the difference between no push-ups
and 10 push-ups is the whole game
because if they do that 10 push-ups they
taught themselves to go from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
that's the thing that's missing for most
people you have great ideas I believe
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you're not acting enough not
in a big enough way not consistently
enough there's too much time planning
and thinking and over analyzing and
worrying about judgment instead of just
getting out there and actually doing
so planning is important it's just not
the first step you burn all of your
boldness and creativity and energy on
the planning you wake up the next day
and you think I can't go do that big
scary crazy thing or instead as soon as
you get the idea the best thing you can
do with your energy with your boldness
with your confidence in that moment in
that idea that you just created is go do
something about it and teach yourself
that you're the kind of person who comes
up with great ideas who trust their
great ideas who doesn't over analyze
anymore and just puts them out into the
world and builds momentum that's going
Brick by Brick
if you want to see more of my husband
Evan Carmichael's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you're gonna enjoy I'll see you
there and continue to believe the
difference between you hating and loving
your life is perspective as Marcus
irelia said the impediment to action
advances action what stands in the way
becomes the way